Now that we discussed softer process models, there is
another important point I want to cover, because it's going to
be useful for your projects. Documenting the activities carried out
during the different phases of the softer lifecycle, is a
very important task. The documents that we produce are used
for different purposes, such as communicative details of the software
systems. To difference the colors, ensure the correct implementation of
the system, facilitate maintenance, and so on. There are standardized
document that are provided by IEEE that you can use
for this purpose. However, they're kind of heavyweight. So for the
project in this class, when we will need them, I will
rather use this lightweight documents. That we created by modifying the
original ones, and make them a little simpler. In this,
our documents are actually used, while teaching this class in the
past. So they're well tested and work well for the kind
of projects that we will perform. I provide information on how
to access these documents in the class notes.